since her film debut in 1994 scarlett
johansson has become one of the most
recognizable and successful actors in
hollywood
here are a few of the most critically
acclaimed roles that johansen has
portrayed throughout her career
from independent efforts to blockbuster
smash hits
still johansen's best reviewed film on
rotten tomatoes
lost in translation was hailed as a
revelation upon its release in 2003
both for its leading performance by bill
murray and for sophia coppola's stylish
and elegant direction
however it's johansen's performance that
gives the movie the profound sense of
existential loneliness
that coppola's films are known for
johansen plays charlotte a recent
college graduate visiting japan
adrift in her life and uncertain about
her future charlotte befriends
fading actor bob played by murray who
feels similarly lost as he flounders
through middle age
the two keep each other company for a
few days in tokyo forming a deep bond
over their mutual sense of alienation
the film landed oscar nominations for
best picture best director and
screenplay for coppola and best actor
for murray
although johansen was unfortunately
snubbed regardless lost in translation
was declared an instant classic by many
critics
terry lawson of the detroit press summed
up the general appeal
writing there is real magic afoot in
lost in translation
the sort that is created not at the wave
of a wizard's wand but by the coming
together of two wayward souls
although johansen didn't get much screen
time in avengers infinity war her iconic
portrayal of the mcu's natasha romanov
otherwise known as black widow played a
pivotal role in the grand cinematic
finale that was
avengers and game as one of the few
avengers left standing after the snap
johansson plays a hero worn down by loss
and despair
endgame provides black widow with an
emotional send-off as she
spoiler alert sacrifices herself to help
save the world
however the cosmic dust had barely
settled on end game
before marvel head honcho kevin feige
announced a black widow standalone movie
in july 2019.
it may have taken nine years since the
first avengers movie for johansen to get
her own film
but it's certainly better late than
never for her legions of fans
although the movie was delayed multiple
times black widow is currently slated to
hit theaters in july 2021
while johansen is primarily known for
her live action work
she has also lent her voice to a number
of prominent films
including the jungle book isle of dogs
and the spongebob squarepants movie
however her most acclaimed voiceover
work to date was her role as an
artificially intelligent operating
system
in her written and directed by spike
jones the near-future sci-fi film which
won an oscar for jones original
screenplay
chronicles the romantic misadventures of
sad sack writer theodore twombly played
by joaquin phoenix
who finds himself falling in love with
the artificially intelligent virtual
assistant
samantha it's easy to see why theodore
falls for samantha
even though she has no physical form
samantha's soulful personality
humor empathy curiosity and intelligence
can
all be felt through johansen's voice
alone samantha also conveys a certain
wistfulness about the experience of
living that feels all too human
despite her artificial nature critics
were charmed and dazzled by jones vision
with empire magazine declaring jones has
made a sweet
smart silly serious film for our times
only set in the future alongside taiko
ytt's jojo rabbid
johansen earned one of her first two
oscar nominations in 2019
for noah bombach's marriage story a
searing portrayal of divorce
marriage story sees johansen play nicole
a former teen star married to charlie a
theater director
played by fellow oscar nominee adam
driver when nicole wants to move to los
angeles to advance her career
even though charlie wants to stay in new
york their already troubled union begins
to slide towards dissolution
bombach himself has said that the film
is semi-autobiographical
partially based on his divorce from
actor jennifer jason lee
while bombach's sympathies are clearly
biased in charlie's favor
johansson still brings an enormous
amount of sympathy and relatability to
the character of nicole
critics gushed about the film and the
performances with moira macdonald of the
seattle times raving
johansson and driver are remarkably
heartbreakingly good in every scene
ghost world was an early critical
success for johansen
and an important transition from her
career as a child actor though she was
only 16 upon its release
the 2001 movie co-written and directed
by terry swygoff
is a mature and serious film about two
young women facing an
uncertain world after their high school
graduation for johansen
ghostworld adapted from daniel klo's
comic book series 8-ball
was also her first foray into a genre
that would catapult her into the highest
ranks of international stardom
the movie stars thora birch as enid a
classic generation x archetype
ironic lost and darkly cynical johansson
plays the role of her best friend
rebecca who is slightly more tethered to
reality and their difference in outlook
eventually leads the girls to having a
falling out
some people are okay but mostly i just
feel like poisoning everybody
ghost world was not very popular with
audiences but it was widely praised by
critics who appreciated its offbeat
sense of humor
emotional honesty and unsparing
depiction of teenage angst
as roger ebert wrote i wanted to hug
this movie it takes such a risky journey
and never steps wrong
it creates specific original believable
lovable characters
and meanders with them through their
inconsolable days never losing its sense
of humor
the culmination of phase one of the mcu
the avengers
proved that marvel movies were here to
stay the movie grossed more than 1.5
billion dollars and was beloved by both
audiences and critics
with a certified fresh score of 91 on
the tomato meter with almost 25 minutes
of screen time
johansen's black widow is the third most
prominent character in the avengers
after iron man and captain america even
if her role in the avengers isn't as
dramatically juicy as the one she gets
in captain america the winter soldier
she still gets her fair share of heroic
moments especially as the avengers save
new york from thor's brother loki
and his legions of alien henchmen in the
final act
while critics lauded the movie's action
and special effects
many were equally impressed by the
performances of the avengers themselves
in his review of the film for the
atlantic
christopher orr wrote that johansen's
black widow is quote
far more interesting than she was in
iron man 2 and that the cast in general
is excellent down the line and plays
well together even
perhaps especially when their characters
don't
the 2014 captain america sequel the
winter soldier was something of a
welcome departure for the marvel
cinematic universe
phase two of the mcu had gotten off to a
bit of a rocky start with a successful
but uninspired iron man 3 and the
middling
thor the dark world both films had done
well at the box office
but it was clear the mcu needed a fresh
approach the winter soldier delivered by
fusing its typical superhero fare
with elements of the spy thriller genre
popularized by classic films like
the parallax view and three days of the
condor critics were impressed with the
winter soldier's action set pieces
and its topical narrative about the
price of freedom and security in the age
of surveillance
as black widow is the primary avenger
featured alongside captain america in
the film
johansson benefited from the film's
acclaim and was subsequently prominently
featured in avengers age of ultron
but while that film's reputation may
have faded over the years the winter
soldier has emerged as an
mcu favorite with johansson providing a
big part of its continuing appeal
among both casual viewers and marvel
fanatics
johansson reunited with iron man 2
director john favreau
for his 2014 passion project about a
middle-aged chef
and his bold attempt to reignite his
creative spirit favreau plays the
titular chef carl casper
and johansson is molly the hostess at
the restaurant casper worked at for 10
years before his very public midlife
crisis meltdown
you're not getting to me okay okay
you're not getting to me
favreau and johansen have a natural
chemistry in this film
stuffed with stars as it is with
delectable dishes including dustin
hoffman
sophia vergara and robert downey jr
johansen's molly is just as appealing as
any of the cuisine on display which is
no small feat in a movie guaranteed to
have you craving a gourmet meal from
beginning to end
critics were mostly charmed by the light
comedy which sits at 87 percent on the
tomato meter
praising the cast the soundtrack and of
course the delicious looking food
writing in little white lies chris blum
called the movie a
sassy and mouth-watering concoction
bursting with flavor
given her comic abilities and previous
experience as a sultry femme fatale type
in post-war los angeles in the black
dahlia
johansson was a no-brainer to join
george clooney channing tatum
rafe fines francis mcdormand and tilda
swinton
in the all-star cast of hail caesar a
coen brothers comedy set in 1950's
hollywood
johansen plays deanna morin a character
based off of actress esther williams
who performs in synchronized swimming
routines that were popular at the time
when diana's unplanned pregnancy
threatens her career and the studio's
bottom line
a studio fixer played by josh brolin is
tasked with covering it up
although audiences had mixed reactions
critics enjoyed the movie
praising the coen brothers playful
spirit its performances
and its nostalgic reflection on
hollywood's golden age
the guardian's mark commode wrote of the
film as a whole its utterly chaotic and
ridiculously indulgent and it would
amount to intolerable cruelty
where hale sees her not so consistently
uproariously
affectionately funny johansen has carved
out a niche for herself in the science
fiction genre more than most of her
fellow a-list actors
in addition to her many appearances in
the mcu and her
the actor has also headlined michael
bay's the island
the surprise global hit lucy and the
controversial live-action remake of
ghost in the shell
but while under the skin is sci-fi this
indie film has little else in common
with those big budget commercial affairs
a product of gorilla filmmaking under
the skin surrounded johansen with real
people
not actors and captured much of its
unscripted footage with hidden cameras
the movie is light on action in favor of
a detached cerebral story about a
feminine alien
played by johansen who uses her good
looks to hunt down men throughout
scotland
and lure them back to her dark lair to
consume them however as soon as she
appears to identify more traditionally
as a human woman
she finds herself going from predator to
prey although a box office failure
under the skin found favor with critics
and scholars who read it as a feminist
allegory about gender inequality
it also showed off johansen's continued
desire to take on challenging
and cryptic roles outside of the usual
blockbusters
taika waititi won the best adapted
screenplay oscar for his anti-hate
satire
jojo rabbit which made waves upon its
release for its unique take on world war
ii the film stars roman griffin davis as
the titular jojo a young german boy
whose imaginary best friend is a
caricature of adolf hitler
played by ytt himself while the film was
marketed as a comedy
johansson's role as jojo's mother rosie
serves as the emotional core of the film
as she struggles to balance being a
single mother to a blindly nationalist
child
with hiding a jewish teenager from the
nazi forces
critics and audiences alike enjoyed jojo
rabbit praising its humor
charm and anti-hate message however as
with many comic takes on hitler and
nazis
jojo rabbit generated his fair share of
controversy
with joanne laurier writing that the
movie inadvertently or not
trivializes nazism and turns people away
from a study of the concrete historical
processes that produced such horrific
carnage
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you